um and and my question genuine question
why do you get married why do people
like you get married why insult
religious people by making a mockery of
the sacrament guys if I'm being honest
like I I think marriage is such a holy
sacrament that barely anybody deserves
keyword deserves some people get it
because of God's grace I really I really
think rarely people actually deserve
marriage and so my question and you know
the people that do get married that have
had crazy pasts they at least put it
aside and and start something new and
beautiful but what you're seeing with
with him really is making a mod like
they could have did this before they got
married but it's like then why get
married if God isn't at the center it's
it's supposed to be a religious
Sacrament with God that's that's what
marriage is